[Music]
what up blog kind of interesting day at
an airport and Seattle good day in LA
bunch of meetings
kind of help their scout today I don't
they really know what you got we're at
the CBS a lot Gary just ran in for a
meeting
can't film I like themes add a real
simple a lot of judgment just a lack of
perspective in the system just a lot of
judgment out there
this the abundance of opportunity is
sometime think a lot about people keep
thinking that if somebody gets something
it comes out of them which is ridiculous
I just think people are short term short
term mentality my friends like life is
long
just impatience and security it's all
the themes man this is a mindset game
and you know I'm just trying to continue
to put out positivity and practicality
which is like empathy people are like
confused a lot of confusion but
just so much good I'm seeing like
everyday hundreds of emails DMS of
people getting inspired finally going
good to go into action and you know the
the principles you know this is a
marathon I don't know what episode this
is what are we in the 400s now
[Music]
same [ __ ] for 60 something 46 fourth
episode and four thousand 67 it's all
gonna be the same [ __ ] unless you get
your operating system your dome your
mindset into a balanced place you're
gonna struggle you're gonna do that
you're gonna be off center and so I just
wish you guys so much happiness and that
starts within and that starts to relight
like if the voice in your head isn't
good
and there's insecure or you don't love
yourself you've just got to understand
that that was put in your head by
somebody by something and you think it
get the [ __ ] out and my mission is to
help you kick get the [ __ ] out so
grinding got a lot done was that William
Morris working on some projects there I
was in the studio working on some
projects there just had a meeting with
Ryan Fay executive from Boehner more
caffeine in LA
just you know Rich Eisen some good
content there we can't have kids who
live in Miami walking around with Steph
Curry jerseys why I don't like this
thing that is underlining which is young
children and grown men and women are
using sports teams to subsidize their
lack of self-esteem they think that
putting on a Tom Brady Jersey at
Minnesota means they're winning I need
them I need a news alert for everybody
that team is winning you're not a winner
you root for a winner just uh do my
thing - now hold on to the airport right
you yeah you're going through this thing
called a private suite oh I got some
sort of thing yeah oh yeah yeah yeah you
know a few of you here and then I flew
back to cut it private suite
don't be Vance until your fancy
[Music]